welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode
38 i can't believe i'm at 38 38 with dr
andrew huberman andrew huberman is a
researcher and professor
at the university of stanford's school
of medicine
he specializes in the field of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
and is currently performing research
into the effects of stress on the brain
effective stress management techniques
and visual impacts of degenerative
diseases in the eyes and the brain
we spoke about stress management
obviously
and different neurotransmitters and what
they do which is something i think
everyone should know a little bit about
we covered sleep screens and what you
can do for your eye health and more
this episode is brought to you by
trulocal the meat shipping company that
i get all my meat from
i recommend their lamb wild turkey wild
salmon i guess it's not wild turkey
wild salmon maybe they're wild turkey i
don't know and grain fed rib eyes in
strip loins and roasts
i've been using them for about two years
getting boxes every two weeks
that are flash frozen and shipped from
the local farmers to me
this way i know i'm supporting local
which is important to me
ah that makes me feel warm and fuzzy on
the inside and of course
i'm getting high quality meat which i'm
very picky about because i only eat meat
use code mp at truelocal.ca that's
trulocal.ca codemp
for free steaks with your box and to
show true local you came from here
if you want to support local farmers and
get sustainably raised meat this is a
great way to do it
i hope you enjoyed this episode if you
do remember to hit subscribe and leave a
review
[Music]
andrew huberman welcome to my podcast
great to be here thanks so much for
having me could you
start off by giving the listeners a
brief background about
you and what it is that you do sure so
i'm a professor of neurobiology and
ophthalmology at stanford school of
medicine
so i have a lab and we work on two
problems
one is we're committed to trying to find
ways to regenerate
neurons nerve cells in the brain and
spinal cord but we
focus on a part of the brain that most
people don't consider a brain which is
the visual system and eyes and the
reason for that is there's a lot of
blindness in the world people who can't
see or losing their vision
over 70 million people are losing their
vision due to a disease called glaucoma
which many people have heard about
so big effort of ours is try and figure
out solutions to that how to halt that
vision loss and reverse it
and then i have a separate lab which
works on
states of mind and those include brain
and body so when people say mind they
usually think about everything above the
neck but
um we're really interested in stress
we're interested in sleep
we're interested in creativity we're
interested in
all the kinds of states that one could
imagine and so my life basically
consists of having post-docs and
students who are running around doing
experiments
we do a little bit of work on mice but
we mainly work on humans now which is
very gratifying for me that was
always a long-term goal to work um with
humans
and on humans and we run clinical trials
we do basic studies
and i do a little bit of teaching i used
to do a lot of teaching in the classroom
but now i mostly just teach
medical students so that's my what my
professional life consists of um pretty
much 364 days a year
so wow okay that's that's great uh there
are a couple of things i
definitely want to delve into um which
would be stress and sleep
uh and then i have a plethora of other
questions to throw at you but i would
like to
start with uh if you're under chronic
stress
whether that be from being ill or family
member being ill
or i don't know being worried about
covid
if you're under chronic stress what kind
of effect does that have on your brain
yeah so this is a really important
question
so stress is this generic response that
was wired into really all organisms
individual cells can have a stress
response to temperature even
or to chemicals or something but as a
whole organism which is made up of a lot
of different cells
when we're in stress the most typical
response
is that chemicals get deployed in the
brain and body
that make us want to mobilize make us
want to move
those chemicals are dumb they don't know
anything about what's causing the stress
and you know we hear this narrative
around oh you know stress was designed
to protect us from large predators and
animals and it's this
uh you know inefficient unfortunate
carryover
of evolution but actually that's wrong
it it's it's a
masterful design that a generic
mechanism was created that would just
make us want to move
or at least cue us to what kind of
information might be in the in the
environment that a few minutes before we
weren't noticing
so that's the acute stress response
that's like in a moment
um you're going to miss your train um
the one that
many people probably can relate to is
you go to your credit card bill and
there's a charge you don't recognize and
all of a sudden
your vision folk you know focuses it on
you don't see anything else you don't
hear anything else
these kinds of things chronic stress
is when those blips in those chemicals
and that activation
happens frequently enough that
eventually what starts to happen to the
nervous system is one of
two things really either we start
feeling like we
we are agitated and want to move all the
time we can't slow
down we can't sleep we can't rest we
can't disengage
or we start to feel depleted and
exhausted
and sometimes we feel kind of
combination of those two things
so the way i like to think about chronic
stress is if you think about
stress is when you can either be very
tired and it's hard to get into action
you're just exhausted
it's like you open up your email or you
open up your phone or your
there's a huge number of things weighing
down on you
and you can feel as if you can't get
into action easily enough so fatigue
right and that's one form of stress and
then on the opposite end of the spectrum
is when you have too much agitation
there's a desire to move when movement
is inappropriate
yeah and chronic stress that we can say
the hallmark of chronic stress
is that people start jumping back
between these states
almost unpredictably so they're feeling
really keyed up then they're feeling
exhausted then they're feeling
like they can't get anything done but
then they're feeling agitated about the
smallest things and irritable
and that's because the the systems of
the body these chemicals and the
receptors that where those chemicals
park
and cause their actions because that's
what the chemicals don't do anything on
their own
they have to kind of fit into these
parking spots we call receptors and then
they
have all their effects when those
receptors get saturated and overworked
or over activated cells actually start
changing their gene expression
in order to deal with that and you start
reshaping your
the organism you know in some cases the
person into one that
is kind of discombobulated it doesn't
know when to be active and when to be
asleep and so a lot of
the work of my lab and other labs that
centered around how to deal with chronic
stress
is to try and figure out how do you
reset the whole organism
and how do you do that quickly so i hope
that answer your question there may be
one or two things i'll just mention
uh your father is an academic so you're
probably used to academics um we kind of
just spool into one thing or the next
although he's far more
eloquent and succinct than i am i i i
you're gonna say far more spewy
which is um you know there's this notion
of adrenal burnout
i don't think any serious physicians
either in standard medicine or nearby
consider adrenal burnout a real
phenomenon the adrenals don't burn out
your adrenal glands which sit right
above your kidneys in the lower back
they don't run out of adrenaline the
receptors can get over
saturated so they're no more parking
spots
but then you'd say well then that should
make people more calm right
so what happens is there is a syndrome
called adrenal insufficiency syndrome
where their drink where the adrenals
actually don't make
enough adrenaline but for most people
feeling exhausted or
anxious or some combination of those
because of chronic stress
what's happening is that the nervous
system
not the adrenal glands but the nerve
cells that that
deploy that adrenaline and that respond
to it is out of whack the neural
plasticity the change in those neural
systems has gone
a bad direction unfortunately neural
plasticity is the way to re-anchor those
and get them back on track
so adrenal burnout is not a real thing
it sounds good but it's not a real thing
adrenal insufficiency is a real thing
but the key is that neural plasticity is
the remedy
by which one can re set the nervous
system so that it
isn't all out of whack in these ways
okay
so i've got a bunch of questions about
that but first just in case anyone
listening doesn't know can you give
a very brief overview about what um this
like neurotransmitter and a receptor
just is so people i know most people
probably
listening probably do know but if they
don't we might want to cover that very
briefly
sure so um neurons which are just nerve
cells
communicate through two means one is by
the release of chemicals
they just spit chemicals out into the
space around them
and by electricity literally like the
kind of electricity that travels down
wires
that connect devices like phones and
computers they
use electricity and certain chemicals
promote the activity of certain neurons
and other chemicals promote the activity
of others
so we've all probably heard of dopamine
which is this molecule involved in
motivation and reward it makes us feel
good
drugs of abuse like cocaine and
amphetamine lead to massive
amounts of dopamine released in the
brain that one would never
experience without those drugs that's
why they're so detrimental
and chemicals like serotonin promote the
activity of other neurons which tends to
make us feel
safe and as if we have enough um
we are when we have a lot of serotonin
in our system we tend to
approach things from us from a state of
um
feeling as if we have capability because
the serotonin system sets that feeling
of calm and confidence
in the whole organism this is true in
dogs this is true in humans
this is true in lobsters as you know in
the lobsters they do some other things
as well this is the work that your your
father has referred to many times and
that you refer to as well
so these chemicals don't do anything on
their own
the way they travel through the body and
brain and make certain neurons active
and not others
is because certain neurons have the
receptors for serotonin and therefore
serotonin can can cause those neurons to
be active
certain neurons have the receptors for
dopamine and therefore
when dopamine is released it can cause
those neurons to be active
so we have areas in our brain where we
have serotonin neurons in area
of the brain where we have dopamine
neurons and the way to think about the
brain
in a really simple but i think accurate
way is to think about not as individual
brain areas controlling things like
hippocampus for memory
or amygdala for fear but rather to think
about
neural circuits different brain areas
that are active in different sequences
much like keys on a piano would be
activated in different sequences to lead
to a particular song
different brain areas will be activated
in particular sequences in order
to lead to a particular state of mind or
a particular bias to be
for instance agitated or happy or asleep
so these chemicals tilt us toward
particular outcomes
they create probabilities they don't
create outcomes
they create probabilities that certain
things will happen so if someone is very
low in serotonin
and dopamine they're going to be a
motivated scared
anxious and depressed if somebody is
very high on dopamine to an extreme
but very low in serotonin you can say
almost with certainty
that that person is going to be really
aggro they're going to be always in
pursuit of something something but
they're not going to be
in a mode to kind of feel relaxed and
listen and so
obviously these things are in a dynamic
balance all the time and the cool thing
is that
certain behaviors promote the release of
these different chemicals
certain thought patterns promote the
release of different chemicals and the
chemicals promote certain behaviors in
certain thought patterns so it's
reciprocal
okay i want to get into that for sure
first can you give
can you give up so you covered dopamine
and serotonin and off the top of my head
i know norepinephrine and gaba
are there other main neurotransmitters
the audience should know about before we
continue yeah
i'm glad you mentioned norepinephrine
and gaba norepinephrine
in general is going to bias the organism
toward action it's sort of a gas pedal
without much direction dopamine tends to
be involved in
motivation for particular things and
feelings of reward epinephrine
and norepinephrine they generate a sense
of
mobilization in the body that you want
to move the body or move the mind
if you see um something exciting on uh
you know a social media feed that you're
excited about you're suddenly going to
feel energetic and you're going to want
to pursue more of it that's epinephrine
and dopamine
gaba as you mentioned is involved in a
kind of suppressive response
the best way to describe gaba is um uh
not that i'm
telling you know assuming that people
are age appropriate for it two drinks
two alcoholic drinks and you're or for
some people one who have low alcohol
tolerance
and their gaba will increase
in the in the forebrain which will make
us less inhibited
right in terms of our actions why
because gaba is an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
that suppresses the actions of other
neurotransmitters so
the reason why people after a few drinks
become that kind of social lubrication
where they start speaking more and
saying more
they wouldn't otherwise is you're
actually gaba is releasing
um a kind of relaxation state and it's
suppressing an
activation state that's why if people
drink too much they black out or they
pass out
but normally gaba is involved in the
transition to sleep
and a healthy balance of gaba and one
other neurotransmitter which is acetyl
or it's a neuromodulator actually
um i'll explain the difference is
acetylcholine and acetylcholine is
involved in focus
acetylcholine is what allows us to dial
our attention into a particular task
or a particular thought train whereas
with
things like dopamine and norepinephrine
and gaba without anything to focus that
we get the states of body and mind alert
or relaxed or driven or feeling lazy
but we don't they don't have any
direction to them acetylcholine is like
a spotlight of attention
so if you're very interested in the
outcome of a particular endeavor or what
someone has to say
acetylcholine is literally released deep
in the brain
and it causes certain neurons in the
brain to be more active than all the
others around it in
kind of a spotlight and this is probably
familiar to people
both in terms of negative events or
positive events the best example is we
just had this big election
in the states it's still somewhat
unresolved as you know
and every time there was a kind of a key
battle state
people's attention would just zoom into
that and that would become
the attention so their acetylcholine was
literally lighting up whatever areas of
their brain
were involved in i don't know for one
moment it was the state of arizona
then it was nevada and so along with
that comes
a huge batch of information
related to whatever somebody has in
terms of their preconceived notions
about arizona or nevada their candidate
etc
so it's acetylcholine norepineps
acetylcholine for focus norepinephrine
for
energy dopamine for motivation and
reward serotonin for feelings of
calmness and safety it's accompanied by
oxytocin
often and then gaba as you mentioned for
feelings of
relaxation and the transition to states
where
um one might not need to put quite as
much attention into every detail
of every action or thing that they're
thinking about so think right before
you're going to sleep
while you're relaxing with your family
or um
you know if you've had a you know if
you've had a you know a
little glass of bourbon or something and
you're feeling really relaxed you could
say
gaba serotonin right at least at the one
whiskey state
uh stage okay awesome that was great
um so two questions just from that one
um
so i used to take adderall a lot of
adderall for idiopathic hypersomnia
um not for focus but that made me and it
makes everyone just focus in
in in an insane amount right it was
ridiculous
um if you take that kind of thing does
it
work with acetylcholine or on
acetylcholine or
is that just dopamine yeah great
question
so the um adderall and things
like it like modafinil and other things
that um are designed for
originally were were created by the
pharmaceutical industry for things like
adhd
um and for modafinil it was
is often uh prescribed as an
anti-narcolepsy drug so when people have
trouble the falling asleep too often for
excessive sleepiness
they mainly increase norepinephrine they
do have
subtle effects on the acetylcholine
system but they're really ramping up
what we call top-down processing so
um our forebrain our prefrontal cortex
um to be specific
has what's called this capability of
top-down processing so
if you're feeling agitated or tired or
hungry you're able to suppress certain
behaviors
a child or a puppy can't do that a child
sees a cookie reaches for the cookie
a puppy sees a wire puts it in its mouth
drops the wire pivots to something else
as animals of all kinds humans and
and dogs etc age or get older they have
i know you've got a young a young child
at home right she's at the stage where
presumably she can
control a lot of her behaviors but
sometimes especially as we get
tired it becomes much harder to suppress
action yeah and that's because the
prefrontal cortex requires
this nora norepinephrine we call it
noradrenergic or norepinephrine
activity in order to exert top down
control we know this because in humans
or in
animals where they have damage to the
frontal cortex everything is a stimulus
you put something in front of them and
they just kind of pivot to it behavioral
inhibition
is because of this top down control and
adderall is very interesting because
it's often prescribed to children
and my psychiatry colleagues i've asked
them about this like it doesn't make
sense
why do you want to make them more
agitated but it turns out there's so
many receptors
for norepinephrine in that prefrontal
cortex
top-down control pathway that
the goal of giving the the the goal at
least on paper of
giving a child adderall is to teach
those circuits to be active so that
through mechanisms of plasticity of
changing
your brain circuits the top-down control
mechanisms
learn essentially how to suppress
behavior
which tells us something very important
that our attention is normally very
broad or it's jumping around like a
couple of spotlights all over the place
top down control puts them on to one
thing or sometimes two things
but a puppy is like this looking
everywhere all the time
a very fatigued person before they
become exhausted
and pass out is like this we've become
discombobulated
non-linear adderall is designed to use
those top-down
mechanisms of the prefrontal cortex that
allow us to direct our attention
now that experiment on humans has been
going on for the last 10 20
years some people achieve great benefit
and relief from things like adderall
other people
suffer quite a lot and the side effect
um
pathways just cause more problems than
they feel is worth taking the drug it is
a very powerful drug there's no question
about it what was your experience with
it
like i said i was taking it for
idiopathic hypersomnia and i tried
modafinil but
um it turns out there's one i don't know
what it is genetic predisposition where
it doesn't work it didn't work at all
for me so i tried that
um i tried another i can't remember what
it was called but
adderall worked insanely well um
when i finally started out my health i
didn't need it and it stopped working
the same way it used to
so it used to give me enough energy i
was on a high dose so i was on 40
milligrams extended release in the
morning
um and the main i think i was more
irritable
i had less of a sense of humor it
completely destroyed my appetite
um but i could focus like crazy i could
work
and i could actually get out of bed in
the morning but um it would the physical
effect like my heart would pound
and i needed a fairly large dose to be
able to counteract the fatigue
um but i would say compared to not being
on it when i was ill
it was extremely beneficial and it
actually allowed me to do the research
that i did in order to be able to get
off of it and figure out my health
so it was not pleasant but it was but i
figured out my health on it so
that was my experience that's
interesting you know that
the ability to have enough energy to
sense enough energy to lean into
the pursuit of other things that can
lend themselves to health is
is such a powerful one i'm familiar with
your with your a bit of your journey
with
um with different uh intake of different
foods and the
carnivore diet or lion diet i think i
think as do you refer to it
what's interesting is that fasting
creates
a an increase in noradrenaline
yeah and dopamine in the short term and
that makes sense because as creatures we
were designed to
make sure that we have enough food
there's a reason why we feel sleepy
after we eat it's not just because our
gut is filled with blood
and we've diverted a lot of blood away
from our brain and other areas of our
body it's because
um there's a release of serotonin
associated with that
in addition when we fast or when we are
taking in very low levels of starches
and carbohydrates
so pure meat diet carnivore diet
ketogenic diets of these sort
you're creating a slightly adrenalized
or noradrenergic nor adrenaline state
in the brain and body and so some people
many people will find that it's easier
for them to focus their attention
oh yeah because because they're engaging
these chemical systems
and again it speaks to the fact that
these chemical systems like stress
or focus and the neural circuits
associated with them were not designed
for any one particular diet or one
particular
life strain or life goal they were
designed to be generic mechanisms of
chemical deployment
to recruit certain categories of
brain areas and body areas to bias our
behavior toward
sleep hunting
learning uh social bonds you know they
they push us down these pretty broad
categories it's not like the supermarket
where there's like one product for
everything
or amazon it's more like they push us
towards active or inactive
focused or unfocused and diet has a huge
impact on these i should just mention as
long as we throughout this thing about
meat which is that
red meat in particular is rich in a
amino acid called a l-tyrosine
l-tyrosine
is the building block of dopamine and
noradrenaline
actually norepinephrine is made from
dopamine and dopamine is made
from l-tyrosine serotonin is made from
l-tryptophan
and carbohydrates and some white meats
like turkey are rich in
all tryptophan and so these are manufa
all these neurotransmitters that we talk
about are manufactured
from food originally food-ingested amino
acids
doesn't mean they're made in the gut but
they are derived from
amino acids that come from food
interesting
well my i mean my brain state changed
dramatically
uh from from switching up my diet and
originally i think my issues were
like no serotonin very very low
serotonin um
and perhaps a little bit too much
dopamine
actually um but that seems to me my
issue and
diet thank goodness fix that uh i wanted
to before i forget
you were talking about gaba and alcohol
why is it that
some people seem to drink and they'll
have a few drinks and they'll fall
asleep and then there are some people
that'll have a few drinks and they'll
get more and more
hyped up what's the difference there
question
so it has to do with um receptor
sensitivity
um they're well known um although not
unfortunately there the information
about it hasn't been distributed uh as
much as it
should is but you know in different
cultures different people with different
genetic backgrounds there are true
differences
in both receptor levels as well as
the enzyme alcohol dehydrogenase that
that can that can actually digest
alcohol if you will so like lactose and
some people are lactose intolerant
it's because they don't make enough
lactase right the enzyme anything that
ends ase
is an enzyme just means it breaks things
down so protease breaks down protein
lipase breaks down lipids
alcohol deodorant ozone ace breaks down
alcohol so in
um certain asian cultures for instance
there there's a
genetic predisposition towards low
levels of alcohol dehydrogenates where
alcohol can actually be poisoned to
people
because the body can't metabolize it
other cultures they
and genetic backgrounds people have more
of this now there's also an interesting
phenomenon with alcohol where about
eight percent of people i think that is
i
don't um quote me on the eight is
somewhere around between five and ten
percent of people
who ingest alcohol get a significant
increase in dopamine release
which so it makes them it makes them
excited
and kind of amped up and motivated to do
more even at levels of alcohol intake
that um would normally cause people to
want to just
pass out or blackout and those people
have a strong
uh predisposition towards full-blown
alcoholism they need to be careful with
alcohol because these are the people
that can
you ever yeah well it's been years since
college but you look around late in the
night and there are a couple people who
are still just drinking as if
they've been drinking all night and
somehow they're not taken out of the the
game like everyone else's
and yet those people often are very
impaired in terms of their motor
function but they have tons of energy so
these are often the people
get behind cars people are blacked out
drunk sometimes do that too but
most people as they drink more and more
what happens is those four brain
circuits
initially shut down they become
uninhibited that's the chatter
early night at a party or in a bar
you're just hearing lots of chatter in
the days when
you know people went to parties and bars
did that
yeah who may still be doing that um and
so you hear a lot of noise
and then as time goes on the areas of
the brain that are involved in
sleep and sawmill and start to take over
and people start
slurring their words they start leaning
on furniture
they start you know and that's where
you're starting to see those gaba levels
really
skyrocket and then there's that you know
five to ten percent of people
who are still hard driving and going now
tolerance
involves both the receptors getting
saturated
so people drink you know a lot and i was
you know so
freshman year of college syndrome we're
drinking a lot a lot a lot
and then they can tolerate more alcohol
because the receptors
are accustomed to that meaning they are
either saturated
or they are they're making increased
levels of the enzymes that that digest
alcohol there's some people get drunk
fast and sober fast
and there's some people have one drink
and they're kind of drunk for a while
um a lot of variation all has to do with
receptor differences
and many of which are genetic
genetically related okay uh let's go
back to stress
so say you've been chronically stressed
or been through something traumatic and
you're in like hyper-stimulated mode how
do you but
the stress is over how do you
go back to what you used to be before
you've been
like wired for horror happening
yeah so there are a couple different
categories of interventions um these
will make sense to people just to kind
of
build out an organizational logic there
are behavioral tools
so these involve ingesting nothing
except you know maybe air
there are drug you know prescription
drugs there are
non-prescription drugs there are legal
drugs there are illegal drugs and then
there's brain machine interface
there's a lot of excitement nowadays
mainly because of the the fame and
popularity of elon musk for his other
endeavors
about neural link which is a company
right design kind of
wires in the brain and re reconfigure
neural circuits i have a couple close
friends
um working there we could talk about
neural link if you like and it's yes
please what its goals represent
but in terms of behavioral tools so
a lot of the work that my lab has been
doing um is involved in
trying to identify behavioral tools that
everyone can use because they reflect
the activity of neural circuits that
work the first time and work every time
so i believe when it comes to stress
everybody
from age you know five onward
should have some real-time tools that
they can use when they experience stress
or any level of alertness that is
uncomfortable or inconvenient to them
and they want to bring things down on a
notch
the tool that my laboratory has been
focused on a lot is based on some work
that dates back to the 30s really which
is
um called physiological size so
um just really quickly breathing impacts
our state of mind our state of mind
impacts our breathing it's a
bi-directional pathway this isn't
mysticism
this isn't meditation this is just a
connection
through a pathway called the phrenic
nerve to a skeletal muscle called the
diaphragm
which moves our lungs which moves our
heart so here's the deal
um when we inhale
our diaphragm moves down a little bit
this muscle in our in our gut
that makes a little more space for our
heart our heart actually gets a little
bigger not in any kind of a sentimental
sense but the heart gets a little bit
bigger because there's simply more space
blood flows more slowly through the
large space that's now created
and a signal gets sent to the brain and
the brain sends back the signal it says
speed up the heart rate
so when we inhale diaphragm moves down
and our heart rate goes up
when we exhale the diaphragm moves up
the heart gets a little bit smaller
blood flows more quickly through a
smaller space
a signal gets sent to the brain and the
brain sends back a signal says
slow down the heart this is the basis
the so-called heart rate variability
so in simple terms when we inhale our
heart speeds up
when we exhale our heart speeds down
slows us down
so right off the bat we can say when
people are feeling too stressed
taking a deep breath is going to send
them in the wrong direction
the key is to emphasize exhales to make
exhales longer than inhales
so that's a simple way to for people to
remember it they don't have to remember
all the mechanism
but sometimes people like mechanism the
other way to calm down
quickly is when what as we get stressed
the little sacks in our lungs our lungs
are too big bags but they have tons of
little sacks everywhere
those sacs collapse and what happens is
carbon dioxide
we have oxygen and we have we need to
breathe in and we need to get rid of
carbon dioxide we also need carbon
dioxide we need to get rid of it if it
gets too high and that's the impulse to
breathe
so those sacs start to collapse and if
we inhale
twice the stacks reinflate again so that
when we
exhale we offload a lot of excess carbon
dioxide
now what's interesting is i didn't make
this up this isn't some sort of
like northern california like weird
breathing technique
we all do this in sleep when carbon
dioxide
builds up in our bloodstream too high we
do it under conditions of claustrophobia
so if you've ever been locked in a small
space or if you have claustrophobia
if you if a child is sobbing or if we're
ever sobbing very hard at the end people
will do
right so but we can do this consciously
and it's the fastest way that i'm aware
of
to bring the nervous system down to a
state of more relaxation
so a double inhale ideally through the
nose but it doesn't have to be will
reinflate those sacs
and then you offload all that carbon
dioxide so these are called
physiological size
identified in the 30s studied by jack
feldman's group at ucla
and now by my group at stanford in
humans and
those two techniques emphasizing exhales
double inhale exhales are the fastest
way to decompress the nervous system and
calm down fast
there's one other way to calm down and
control stress
which is less of a real-time tool but is
more about learning how to
tolerate stress so that what you
consider stress
the ceiling on that goes up so it's sort
of like learning when you learn to drive
you don't learn to drive on black ice in
canada
like on the you know i went driving up
there i do some work up in auto
uh from time to time with um some of
your military and i've
been there in summer but in winter
driving up there is for an american
is for uh you know someone from the
states is is frightening because you're
driving along everyone's going really
fast and they know how to drive on
really slick roads
and for me it's like all of a sudden
you're on ice and that's not how you
want to learn how to drive
but you want to learn how to drive an
eye slowly and incrementally and the
same thing is true for our stress system
so the way to do that is to pick
some activity that you feel comfortable
with could be
ice bath could be cold shower could be
in deliberate hyperventilating so many
people have heard of wim hof
or kind of kundalini those breathing
techniques involve doing
really kind of deliberately stressing
oneself
or getting into the ice bath or
something like that maybe it's a martial
art
some way to deliberately increase your
adrenaline
but as my colleague david spiegel who's
our associate chair of psychiatry at
stanford says
it's not just about the state of stress
it's whether or not you had anything to
do with getting there
yeah you chose that or not so if you if
people really want to learn to combat
stress
you can keep those breathing technical
techniques that we just described the
double inhale exhale the long exhales
in the back your pocket in mind for
deployment anytime you want to use them
as well you can cultivate a practice of
three or four times a week
raising your ceiling on your stress
threshold and you do that by doing
maybe 25 or 30 really deep breaths
really ramp up that heart rate
deliberately
and then exhaling it all and learning to
be calm while you still have a lot of
adrenaline circulating in your system
when people do that regularly what they
find is that in real life when they get
that
fraudulent credit card charged or
somebody says something triggering
or whatever the stressor might be they
tend to not experience it
mentally as stressful because they're
familiar with having
high levels of adrenaline in their
system they've effectively learned to
drive their nervous system
under conditions of icy roads whereas
people who never experience stress on a
regular basis they're just not
comfortable there okay wow okay
um so first if you've been medicated i
was medicated with antidepressants from
like 12 till 23. and when i stopped
taking it
what i felt was that i was experienced
that i hadn't
been able to form a proper stress
response because
i had had this antidepressant prop for
my
developmental years is that something is
that accurate
without demonizing antidepressants again
i think for example
for sure for a lot of people but my bias
even though i work in a medical center
you know side i'm surrounded by
physicians and
my bias is always start with behaviors
then
think about diet and supplementation
then think about prescription drugs
except under conditions like you
mentioned before where
people are so back on their heels that
they can't even conceive of
engaging the behavioral stuff i mean
when someone is truly depressed
the idea will get some sunlight get some
exercise
positive social engagement it's almost
cruel to offer those
in because it's sort of like saying you
know what
um you know you're on a tricycle right
up everest
except you know what i'm i know you
don't even have um pedals on that
tricycle
right it's different what's what's cool
about the human brain and body what's so
amazing
is that as we learn to move forward if
we get a little nudged from behind
a chemical nudge or a social nudge or a
family support nudge
that bicycle starts to convert into a
bicycle then it turns into a motorcycle
and the next thing you know
you're heading up on the fast track tram
right but if you people can't get out of
the ditch
there is a place for these these
pharmaceuticals now
the reason why they often cause problems
is two reasons one is that serotonin
neurons in the brain
are not just located in one place
they're located in lots of areas
involved in as you mentioned
you know things like appetite motivation
and drive
so when we artificially or exogenously
as we say by taking in
drugs that increase serotonin when we do
that
we are increasing the activity of all
the serotonin neurons in the brain the
great future of medicine is to figure
out medicines that are targeted to
particular organs and body areas
chemotherapy is
great for killing tumors but it makes
other cells
die die off too other stem cell
populations people lose their hair and
their memory and it's it's
quite hard right so when people take
these
antidepressants that affect the
serotonin system it creates an
artificial sense of well-being and
safety
you have enough now when you have the
sense that you have enough serotonin
remember these these chemicals are dumb
they don't know anything about your
outside life
then there tends to be less motivation
for pursuing
things that would bring you serotonin
like so you know oftentimes they can get
people over the bump but if levels of
serotonin go too high
then people don't feel like they want to
pursue social bonds
they feel anxious because their rebounds
in other systems of neurotransmitters
the brain doesn't like
one system of neurotransmitter to be too
high or too low so again to kind of
get back to a organizational structure
that could be helpful to people
if you're if they are early in the
process of depression
then the things like behaviors exercise
sunlight
social bonds breathing tools are going
to be very beneficial
if they are really back on their heels
or they're at the kind of suicidality
point of course that's where drug
interventions can be very useful
and again this is why working with
people who really what they're doing
board certified physicians and
psychiatrists mds who are very also very
informed on the behavioral tools
i think also represents the great future
of psychiatry because
it can't be just drugs or in some cases
just behaviors
yeah okay that all makes sense uh
let me see yeah the downside i can see
the upside of medications and i was on a
lot of them
and that enabled me to be okay enough to
research how to get better
so that i could solve the underlying
problem and then get off the drugs so
they did
work better than not doing anything so
they definitely shouldn't be
demonized but it would be good if people
knew more about behavioral techniques
and diet and
all these other things like tools people
can use uh
what do you what are your thoughts on
like neotropics
for brain enhancement i know you can
take acetylcholine you can
take uh ala like
there's a plethora of them so what do
you what do you think about those and
you would recommend or just avoid those
and do it more
more natural way what do you think sure
um
so i'll just uh people probably realize
this and i'm not just saying this for
um to protect myself but also to the to
the listeners so i'm not an md i'm a
i'm a phd i'm a so i would say i'm not
an md i don't prescribe anything
i'm a professor so i profess a lot of
things so people can filter that
information through that knowledge i
i just right off i want to mention a
resource that i have no professional
relationship to but i think it's very
very good which is called
examine.com it's a website
um that is a not-for-profit website you
can put in
any supplement l-tyrosine um
cbd anything and they have what's called
the human effect matrix it's this
beautiful very simple and accessible
chart that lists
anywhere from one to three arrows either
up or down of the effect of a particular
supplement
so if you if you put in l-tyrosine for
instance it will tell you
effects on focus effects on heart
effects on physical performance effect
and it will tell you
whether or not the study was done in
mice in post-menopausal women
or in college-aged males and and females
it will give you all that information
totally free links to the studies so
people can assess that it also has a few
warnings
that are not just the boilerplate type
stuff of look if you're
taking mao inhibitors don't take this
the fda won't
say bling it gives you real warnings
which are the sort of like
um has interactions with probiotics
or some people find it makes them too
agitated the kind of
that's important it's a vast
resource and i'm such a fan of what
they're doing because um
you know someone actually took the time
to curate all this information and they
update it all the time
and they're not selling products there
so it's very unbiased
so in terms of nootropics which i think
translates to smart drugs
um you know the most powerful nootropic
that i'm aware of is caffeine
it's one that i enjoy and indulge in uh
regularly
um these days uh coffee and mate tea
are a mainstay for me um caffeine
increases norepinephrine
it does it through um by it's
interesting now that we know a little
bit about enzymes from
this discussion it works on an enzyme
called adenylate cyclase there's the ase
again
which is involved in the cyclic amp
pathway which is atp and energy
so when you drink coffee you adjust that
pathway and it acts as a nootropic
almost purely through increasing levels
of norepinephrine
so bring a little bit more focus a
little bit more a little bit of more
stress but as long as you're not already
agitated it won't make you feel
too agitated now there are there are
nootropics some of which you alluded to
in your question that
attack other or sorry support i should
say other systems in the brain and body
like
acetylcholine so the choline itself
things like alpha gpc and
those chemicals when taken will
tend to make people feel more focused
not to the extreme of
adderall but they'll tend to make people
more focus
in the food world um nuts are
are rich in choline i think eggs might
have choline in them as well
and i'm sure the vegan crowd will tell
me they're all these vegetables that i
have calling too i'll just say i'm
neither carnivore nor
vegan i tend to i'm sort of i don't know
carnivore-ish
with but i do eat starches so i'm don't
have any strong bias there
but we could talk about nutrition if you
like if there are no tropics
like elk that combine l-tyrosine alpha
gpc
and some of the other acetylcholine
stimulating agents
that i've tried them and indeed they
create a
absolute laser focus for work for about
four or five hours
they do tend to create a bit of a dip in
a crash the next day
for me that's how my system works the
next day i'm not feeling my all-time
clearest and best but boy they are
significant the effects are significant
in fact and i have no relationship to
these companies
um people always ask me about companies
i guess normally i'm reluctant
i would go to exama.com there actually
is one um
supplement company however that
manufactures some of these which is up
your way
um they're a canadian company called atp
labs
um okay which which just have there are
other companies as well but they have
very
high uh high degree of stringency in
terms of product testing and
laboratories again they don't pay me a
dime i've nev they've never sent me
anything i haven't paid for directly um
and
i'm an occasional user of these things i
would rather
see people using their own good sleep
and good focus
to engage but look let's face it from
time to time
people i hear about a lot of college
students relying on adderall i'd much
rather
hear about people relying on
supplementation than prescription drugs
when they're not prescribed those drugs
and so you can think like behavior
supplementation and diet
and then um can get you to sort of hear
and then prescription drugs are where
you start getting into conditions of
abuse where people
are always taking adderall to study so
nootropics have their place
but almost all of them involve some
level of stimulation of stimulant
um the atp labs makes
one um that has l-tyrosine and some
other things that doesn't have any
caffeine but you still feel that
stability
that's nice yeah so in any case again
i'm not here to plug
them or or supplement nootropics in
general i think
less that one relies on these things the
better but they have their place
and they're part of the world we're
living in right now i think it would be
foolish and naive for people to think
that they aren't going to have a
prominent role
in learning culture and in focus and
trying people trying to achieve specific
states going forward in the same way
that when i was growing up i got really
into
different you know trying different diet
and supplementation for sports
and my uh the generation two above me
were like can't you just eat a balanced
diet and
clearly the few the food pyramids and
all that stuff has failed miserably
otherwise we wouldn't have the obesity
crisis and the mental health issues we
have so
it's out there explore be nuanced be
smart
but there are some um that's my advice
to people but then
there's real utility out there yeah and
look at interactions
don't take a whole bunch of water unless
you're making sure that it's someone
yeah if someone for instance is supposed
to mania
taking dopamine bad idea
um again yeah it's a case-by-case basis
okay that's probably good to know uh
okay
um i want to cover how to recover
from we we covered stress recovery a
little bit
or what to do to make yourself more
stress resilient which i thought was
interesting you know
you mentioned it when you see little
kids like when i see scarlet cry
if she'll get really upset and she'll do
that thing
um at the end of the cry which i didn't
realize was actually something to
calm you down so that's a fun fact but
say you've suffered from a concussion
or a stroke or some sort of
brain damage are there things you should
focus on
are there ways to speed up your recovery
for those kind of things
yeah so they're really two categories of
approaches for this
um and the first one dovetails with the
stress mitigation techniques that we
were talking about before
which is you know very few of us have a
practice
of systematically and regularly
training up or improving our calming
system
and our ability to sleep so sleep is the
number one
way to restore our cognitive and
emotional capacity it's kind of a duh
at this point right everyone kind of
knows this in matt walker's book why we
sleep
kind of you know really nailed that one
home even more but
really it's because the brain during the
day is trying to always analyze three
things duration path and outcome how
long are things going to last what path
should i take to get there and what's
going to happen if i do that
and constantly update it and 2020 has
been a year of
running multiple multiple what i call
dpos duration path
outcome things in tandem it's like we're
all having to do this much more than
usual
it doesn't matter where you sit on the
on the politic on which side of the
aisle you sit politically or which side
of the aisle you sit in terms of covet
and lockdowns
it's just everyone has to think a lot
more now
sleep is the one time when you're not
doing any duration path outcome
kind of thinking you're just it's just
free floating it's there's no analysis
of time or space that you're controlling
the brain is just meandering through
these different you know duration path
outcome things are surfacing from the
day
meaningless stuff confusing stuff even
in dreams
so that's fine that's sleep but a lot of
people have challenges sleeping
so one of the things my lab has been
working on in collaboration with david
spiegel's lab is to try to figure out
practices that allow us to to turn off
our forebrain and those duration path
outcome types of
computations which have two major
positive effects the first is
they are very restorative and can mimic
sleep
they can't replace it but they can mimic
it the second is they get us better
at transitioning into sleep and staying
asleep
and so most of these practices that
there's sort of two major forms of them
one is a practice it commonly goes
by the name yoga nidra nidra where
it involves long exhale breathing slow
the heart rate
and sometimes there's an audio script
that involves in the kind of more
mystical ones the kind of intentions and
that kind of thing
my lab has stripped away all the kind of
mystical stuff and we we focus mainly on
the breathing part
you can find these scripts on youtube um
the other one is hypnosis
so david spiegel's lab has been very
involved in generating
hip this is clinical hypnosis not stage
hypnosis with a pendant or anything
but clinical hypnosis for pain
mitigation for
trauma for all sorts of medical
conditions and they see
very significant and important uh
effects there
and it and they understand the brain
mechanisms involved if people want those
resources they are completely cost
free um you can find them at a website
called reverie.com i can send you this
as a link if you like to provide to your
listeners or not um
reverie.com and you can download um
those hypnosis scripts
that's helpful they're very helpful and
hypnosis is very misunderstood i almost
wish there was another name for it
because
hypnosis has all these negative
connotations about mind control but this
is self-hypnosis
where people are calming themselves and
then
in doing that what happens in these deep
sleep states and in states of hypnosis
and things like yoga
is the circulation of fluids in the
brain that literally wash out debris
so there's a system in the brain called
the glymphatic system which is like a
plumbing system
is very active in sleep and it literally
washes out the cellular debris
that accumulates during the day and when
we're sleep deprived and after head
trauma
and it washes it out and leads to repair
of the neural systems
and so i believe everyone should have a
couple stress mitigation techniques they
can use in real time
maybe they also have a stress mitigation
tech practice of raising their stress
threshold like we talked about earlier
and everyone i do believe should have
some
practice that they engage in regularly
that allows them to defocus
turn off their brain and get better at
turning off their brain and defocusing
so they can better access these deep
sleep states where the brain is renewed
and
refreshed people without brain damage
learn in those states the actual
reconfiguration of synapses in the brain
happens in deep sleep and depressed not
while we're learning so so many reasons
to do this
now for people with with tbi so i do
some work with military not
particularly on tvi but we have
discussions about you know people that
those um like that fire those big 50
caliber guns you know which basically
sets their brain in a mode like a
woodpecker
you know where the brain is kind of
juggling around in their lot or
people that have a traumatic injury to
the head years and years there's a
hockey players
deal with a lot of this discussions with
some folks from the nhl
a lot of concussion head trauma they
need to get rest
but there's also a growing interest in
what sorts of
activities physical activities can
increase the
the flow of this lymphatic system and
what's and this is early emerging data
but what it appears is is that
total bed rest is not the best idea in
most cases
um unless there's enough you don't want
to get more that doesn't mean go back to
your sport or your practice and get more
injury
but a combination of deep rest and
activity
seems to activate this lymphatic system
to push out
the debris and allow blood flow to
continue to serve the neurons in healthy
ways
so it's a matter of learning to master
the transition between
deep breath states and still maintaining
activity but again that doesn't mean
resubjecting oneself to more head trauma
it just means total bed rest
may not be the best answer and again
these are emerging data i'm not making
medical recommendations
okay how do they know so you're saying
and correct me if i'm wrong but
what you're saying is something like
hypnotherapy if you can accomplish it
properly can give you some of the
benefits of deep sleep
like that brain cleansing thing that
happens when you're deep sleeping
that's what that's what you said right
yeah so
i started cultivating a practice of 10
to 30 minutes a day
five days a week uh not every day of
non-sleep deep rest deliberate
decompression learning to turn off the
mind without two
whiskies okay i've never been a big
drinker but
that works just like eating a big plate
of pasta will turn off your forebrain
too
tryptophan will go up serotonin go up
and you'll basically be enough
the food coma right it's a way of one of
the main ways that human beings have
learned to suppress their cortisol which
is another stress hormone
and shut down their forebrain is to use
carbohydrates and food
we you know i i think it's fair to say
that
we have a i remember a few years ago the
map of the united states
in terms of obesity had a few you know
hot spots
of obesity every state now i think
except for colorado for reasons that are
still
unbeknownst to me is has a you know a
serious obesity issue
you know and and this has nothing to do
with the social evaluation of
people this is all about health and
diabetes and brain function etc
so food is one of the ways that humans
know how to control these
neurotransmitter systems and relax
themselves
i'm saying remember before i my my
biases towards behaviors
then food supplementation then drugs if
they're prescribed and
really needed so behavioral practices
that one can teach themselves to calm
down
either through self-hypnosis or there's
some great scripts
through reverie that that are clinical
clinical tools you can
links to papers and all that that speak
those lab is put out there
things like yoga nidra those are
wonderful tools for
people to teach themselves how to relax
and this is all
self-induced plasticity i would say
after we reach age
25 no one can change in our brain we
have to
but we can change our brain we can't
change anyone's brain after age 25
not positively in any way and children
whatever we expose them to their brain
will
will map to that so i do think my wish
is that children will learn how to
stealth soothe
and you mention that your daughter will
do this double inhale exhale when she's
sobbing that's a natural reflex children
are allowed catharsis
they're allowed to cry and and you know
throw tantrums and
um and as we get older we lose the
uh the permission i think for good
reason to use catharsis we're no longer
allowed to walk up to the person next to
him and just hit him because it
actually makes us feel good we can't
shout out swear words
in class or even on the internet these
days
without consequences when we're children
we get a pass right
so adults have all the same stressors
the stress system doesn't turn off as we
exit childhood
but we don't have a lot of ways to
channel that stress
and so learning how to channel that
stress learning how to hit the release
valve but also
how to self-soothe in ways that are
socially and professionally acceptable
is something that we need to learn how
to do and our species has learned how to
do it mainly by eating and by drinking
and i don't want to demonize those
activities they are perfectly fine in
moderation but
we can all see what happens when they
get out of moderation and so
learning these behavioral tools and
adopting them it takes a little work
but people who've had chronic anxiety
and insomnia
come to us and the studies are still
ongoing and say i'm sleeping so much
better even
better i'm falling asleep so much more
easily and staying asleep
and if you wake up these are great in
the middle of the night these are great
practices to do to shut your brain
off and allow you to go back to sleep
that's fascinating i'm actually going to
try that i've been having
since the last couple years like before
that i was sleeping too much
then i had a baby so i wasn't sleeping
and then both my parents got incredibly
ill
and my sleep has just been a disaster
for deep sleep there isn't any i'll fall
asleep but i'll wake up and there's no
deep sleep so this is going to be
i will definitely try this out and let
my audience know how it goes i used
hypno birthing
um when i gave birth and it it sounded
like some hippie dippy
bs but it was fantastic and i absolutely
nailed uh
calming myself down because i knew all
the chemicals that were released when
you give birth and i didn't want to
screw any of those up by being stressed
out
um so i'm definitely going to look into
this and i will let the audience know
how it goes that's very helpful
one last question that i'm glad i
remembered because you're talking about
children's development how detrimental
is screen time
if it's say it's not a learning activity
say it's
a cartoon or something um how
detrimental is that for
either young young kids and then maybe
12 year olds like
should we be worried should we be
limiting that or eliminating it below a
certain age
yeah so much like adderall um
20 years ago when that really first hit
the market big
i mean we are in the experiment of
screen time now
right it's an ongoing experiment in huma
that humans are doing to themselves and
you know so we don't really have clear
answers there are a couple things that
we know based on just how the visual
system works
that are notes for caution i would say
to parents and
to children and to adults uh who don't
have
kids which is when we view things up
close
there are changes in the optics of the
eyes that
increase our level of called autonomic
arousal but it's sort of a low-level
increase in stress
irrespective of what we're looking at so
it could be
so um i think i know from an instagram
post like your daughter is disney right
so she's looking at disney on an ipad
the disney is pleasant kids love disney
stuff and it's and it's great
so they love the content but their
sphere of attention is really like
tunnel vision
right yeah it's amazing i mean
you know just trying i mean it's the
ultimate babysitter when one needs to
get things done and
they love it and it's and there's a lot
of dynamic learning i'm not out to
demonize technology
i'm from silicon valley i work there
there's a lot of wonderful things that
come from technology
that narrow cone of attention however
should be balanced
by literally viewing things further out
in one's environment first of all it's
well known
that if children view things up close
too much the the eyeball actually
lengthens and the lens focuses
the visual image in front of the retina
in front of the scene
part of the the eye and that's literally
what nearsighted
that's what nearsighted myopia is okay
okay
sorry to interrupt but when my parents
were telling me not to read
like in the dark close up because all i
did when i was a kid was read
and then i actually my short side and it
actually went away with the diet stuff
but i was dead i needed reading glasses
did i actually do that to myself
possibly yeah and it's reversible
that you it but the way it reverses by
looking at things
off in the distance now little children
are not going to get too excited about
looking at a horizon i recommend adults
if
they're on zoom or on their phone a lot
or tablet a lot
or surrounded by closed walls i mean one
of the worst things about the lockdowns
is how much people are already stressed
about the world and its
happenings and then they're not viewing
things at a distance and so there's an
increase in this level of stress and
autonomic arousal
they can be relieved by viewing a
horizon or looking long distance out of
a trend
or even better getting into what's
called self-generated optic flow without
going into all the details when we move
our body either walking
running um cycling not on the peloton
um but when we get outside and we move
optic
flow is known now from a series of about
five really good peer-reviewed studies
to suppress the activity of the amygdala
this area of the brain that's involved
in threat detection and stress
wow so if so when kids get outside
and they're moving around a bit more or
they're in the yard or if
people don't have access to yards just
trying to get them their
sphere of visual attention to be a
little bit further put them a little bit
further from devices
um at some point during the day or away
from devices
that's very helpful so that's sort of
the
the proximity to the device there's
another interaction
that we should be mindful of which is
that we all
should be getting as much bright light
in our eyes never to the point where
it's painful but as much bright light in
our eyes early in the day as possible
ideally from sunlight
but look if you're up in toronto or you
know way up in
the depths of ottawa um did i pronounce
it correctly
ottawa yeah okay sorry okay a lot of
work with a lot of canadians now and
they're always poking fun at my
pronunciation
um uh which is fair uh
fair uh revenge for all the joking that
we did over the years
um it when you're up at those depths
those areas or scandinavia in the depths
of winter there's very little light so
you might need to use artificial light
bright lights from screens during the
day is good because you want as much
bright light in your eyes during the day
that the fear of blue light has led
people to think that they should get
no bright light in their eyes but blue
light from the sun is what
turns on the appropriate timing of
stress hormones and melatonin and all
that stuff
in a healthy way so lots of light early
in the day you don't have to see the
sunrise it's true for kids too
so no staying in the cave early in the
day
devices can provide some stimulation but
really natural light during the day
as much light during the days as safely
possible and then as night comes around
you want to dim devices and really try
and
keep the level of artificial light down
to a minimum
i don't think people have to be in
complete darkness but one thing that's
really helpful is just to set
lights physically low in the environment
instead of overhead lights use
use desk clamps because the neurons in
the eye that's that
reset and kind of wake up our clocks in
our brain and body
those look at the upper visual field and
so if things are set
too high in the environment then people
find themselves falling asleep and then
a couple hours later waking up
because the system is all out of whack
so cool try and view long distance away
from screens that's true in kids and
adults
try and keep things bright mostly
sunlight but also
artificial lights during the day dim the
lights at night
obviously so you're not jet what i call
jet lagged at home where you're screwing
up all your clocks while you're still at
home
and i should mention there is a
phenomenon just to drive this home
called icu psychosis where people go
into the hospital
and because of all the checks that are
being feel like i've had that
and all the lights and the nurses coming
in and flipping on the lights
they actually go psychotic it's well
known
and then when they go home or they get
on a regular light dark schedule
and all the bright lights of all the
machinery is taken away their
sanity is restored it's remarkable and
so you can you can make someone
psychotic by messing up these patterns
and i don't think we're kind of that
level as a culture yet
but i think that children deserve
obviously we wouldn't show them like
inappropriate content
so we also shouldn't deliver good
content in a format that's
not healthy for them part of the reason
i did this hypno birthing thing and i
ended up giving birth at home
is because i was thinking if i go to a
hospital and i'm under a fluorescent
light and there's a whole bunch of
beeping
while i'm trying to do this i'm going to
be so stressed out that the birth is
going to go badly
so i'm surprised that there's actually
something termed icu psychosis but also
not surprised at all um for the saturday
morning card so saturday morning
cartoons would be the best time for
cartoons
morning cartoons not night cartoons
ideally yeah exactly
exactly and and also trying to get some
sunlight during the day get kids into
optic flow moving around
if you if they can just it's the nerdy
term is ambulate
it means just walk if they can just walk
around
ambulate your child if can just walk
around with your child
um or they ride their their their trike
or their bike or or roller skate or
whatever it is that they enjoy
some activity where they're
self-generating optic flow
that is it could be swimming that's an
incredibly resetting
mechanism for the nervous system and you
know
what concerns me is how between the
lockdown and between
all these other things we're
systematically taking away all of
the natural tools that the nervous
system has developed to reset itself
and then and then expecting people to
keep their
you know their sanity and we're really
we're pushing ourselves much harder and
our children much harder than
than we should or they deserve to be so
these are simple cost-free things it
doesn't take long
um and the best way to engage them is to
sort of take a look at one's day
and say okay am i staying in bed early
in the day with the curtains drawn
on a screen for the first 30 minutes
that first hour of waking is really when
it's key to get light in the system
or uh ideally natural light through a
window
or get outside and then bright
artificial light throughout the day
and then in the evening really try and
dim things down
great well that was fantastic um we're
out of time
but i will definitely have you back on
because that only covered that covered
like six of the questions i had
so that was fantastic i think people
will find this incredibly helpful
i certainly did um where can people find
you
well first of all um thanks i i know i
can be a little long-winded so
no no that was great and we covered like
this that was great
okay i strive for thoroughness because i
think people often have a lot of
questions i just want to make sure they
at least have a good jumping off point
but thank you for your your questions
um so i teach
uh neuroscience on instagram and i'll
soon have a youtube i'll
move that over to a youtube channel um
the huberman lab
h-u-b-e-r-m-a-n-l-a-b on instagram i do
short posts on basic neuroscience i do
some practical tool coverage
do some live interviews and discussion
about things everything from optimal
performance effects of nutrition
autism add all things neuroscience on
instagram
and then the youtube channel is just
under my name andrew huberman i have not
launched any content there yet
um but i will starting in january and
there i'll be going more deeply into
specific topics for entire months i'm
um as you probably already know very big
on public education
and trying to take what's known from the
neuroscience and related communities and
try and put that into
the general public so people can make it
actionable if they feel and and
simply to enjoy the knowledge well thank
you again i'm looking forward to the
youtube channel
great thanks and thanks so much for
hosting me i'm a big fan of your podcast
i've been a subscriber long before you
invited me to come on here so thank you
cool
that's awesome okay well thanks again
you